herzlich willkommen ja heute sitzt mir
der wohl bekannteste aber auch
umstrittenste psychiater der schweiz
gegenüber frank urbaniok hat den
hiesigen strafvollzug und den umgang mit
gewalt und sexualverbrechern geprägt
mich kein anderer
nach einer schweren krebserkrankung hat
dass ich aus öffentlichen ämtern
zurückgezogen und unter anderem dieses
dicke buch her geschrieben dass soeben
erschienenes darwin schlägt kommt über
die schwächen der menschlichen vernunft
und die refa taten folgen und über das
wollen wir heute reden herzlich
willkommen frank urbaniok ja fast 500
seiten ging es nicht ein bisschen dünner
ich habe mich bemüht das ursprüngliche
manuskript man noch dicker das ist schon
eine gekürzte version sehr gut das
beruhigt mich ja dahin geht es um den
menschen insgesamt das wesen des
menschen um seine schwächen um die
schatten zu halten auch was ist denn aus
ihrer sicht die gefährlichste
eigenschaft des menschen
die gefährlichste ist wahrscheinlich die
dass er sich aus dem evolutionären trieb
der egoistischen selbstbehauptung keine
hemmungen hat und nach dem motto der
zweck heiligt die mittel
alles platt was drum herum ist oder was
anders ist und dann die bedürfnisse
anderer lebewesen andere menschen
unzureichend berücksichtigt über diesen
egoistischen trip der selbstbewertung
reden wir gleich noch das buch beginnt
mit einer hübschen kleinen geschichte
bei den urzeitmenschen und zwar mit
einem raschen im busch können sie die
geschichte kurz erzählen
ja ich will mit diesem beispiel
eigentlich verdeutlichen dass wir
fälschlicherweise annehmen der verstand
sei dazu da die wirklichkeit
differenziert zu erkennen
die evolution hat etwas ganz anderes im
sinn und das kann man sich an diesem
beispiel klar machen wenn sie sich zwei
urzeitmenschen vorstellen und der eine
ist ein interessierter mensch ein
neugieriger der will die umwelt
differenziert erfassen und der macht
sich jetzt gedanken darüber
was ist das rascheln in einem busch und
dann wird er mit der zeit ein
differenziertes verständnis dieses
phänomens generieren können er wird
sagen das ist mal der wind das sind mal
irgendwelche vögel die da drin sind das
ist mal gar nichts und manchmal ist es
ein löwe er hat ein gutes bild über das
phänomen rascheln im busch jetzt stellen
uns dagegen einen paranoid verteilt den
urmenschen vor der hinter jedem rascheln
einen löwen vermutet der wird natürlich
die präsenz von löwen dramatisch
überschätzen weil wir immer glaubt
rascheln heißt löwe daher sieht die
wirklichkeit falsche anders sieht sie
richtig aber der der sie richtig sieht
wird einmal zu spät loslaufen und
deswegen gefrästen formuliert gefressen
wird gefressen deswegen glaube ich
stammen wie er von dem polit- verteilten
ab in der evolution als von dem an der
wirklichkeit interessierten
ich würde dem beispiel klar machen der
evolution geht es nicht darum richtig
und differenziert zu erfassen die
evolution baut den verstand und den
menschen so dass er bestmöglich überlebt
und da ist richtigkeit und wahrheit sind
untergeordnete ziele und das gilt auch
für die vernunft selbst die selbst ein
produkt der evolution und der zweck ist
auch das überleben nicht die wahrheit
hatte ja erkenntnis das ist und das
widerspricht eigentlich unsere kultur
historischen tradition man hat im
christentum lange zeit gesagt
der verstand ist eine gabe gottes um die
schöpfung gottes zu erkennen und gott zu
erkennen die aufklärung setzt sehr stark
auf den verstand auf die vernunft in dem
sie sagt das ist das instrument mit dem
wir die wirklichkeit differenziert
erfassen können und dann humanistisch
handeln können und ich würde sagen das
potenzial ist da aber der zweck worum es
die vernunft gibt ist ein ganz anderer
die evolution hat nicht gesagt wir
nehmen jetzt irgend ein lebewesen und
das soll jetzt besonders gut die welt
erklären können die evolution hat gesagt
da haben wir eine schlange die hat zu
wenig gift ergeben ein bisschen mehr
gift da haben wir einen löwen dem geben
wir ein kräftigeres gebiss und da haben
wir dieses komische wesen was seit zwei
millionen jahren auf der erde herum
kreuzt sich in der nahrungskette ganz
hinten anstellen muss
das mag aus den knochen kratzt mit
steinen die andere übrig gelassen haben
sagt wird bei dem versuch es mal mit da
investieren vollem verstand und das hat
konsequent hat nicht schlecht schlecht
funktioniert hat ziemlich gut
funktioniert
für die evolution ist es ein 2 und error
und es ist schon es ist ein projekt
würde ich sagen mit chancen und risiken
also es ist nicht von anfang an
ausgemacht gewesen dass das jetzt so ein
erfolgsmodell wird weil sobald man das
macht hat man einen großen kopf schweren
kopf ein schweres gehirn das gehirn
verbraucht sehr viel energie sehr viel
sauerstoff also man kann so sagen wenn
die evolution das versucht dann muss es
schon richtig hinhauen und klappen sonst
ist der versuch gescheitert
aber für die evolution ich rede jetzt
sowas wie die evolution eine person mir
ist natürlich klar es ist ein prinzip
aber auf der anschaulichkeit halber
sagen die emotion denkt sich etwas dabei
und sie denkt sich und sagt ja jetzt
verstand das ausbauen das hat risiken es
könnte ja sein dass dieser mensch dieses
wesen handlungsunfähig wird weil es zu
viel nachdenkt das kennen wir ja auch so
als ein bisschen allgemein weiß hat man
sagt menschen die viel nachdenken sind
vielleicht ein unglücklicher oder
weniger handlungsfähig
das ist eine gefahr 2 vo zu stark der
zwei jahre nach zweifeln zu stark und da
wird die evolution wird sich sozusagen
das ist uns zu unsicher da bauen wir ich
nenne das evolutionäre stoßdämpfer 1
das was sich in jahrmillionen der
evolution bewährt hat stereotypen
automatismen selbstüberschätzung dinge
nach gefühlten wahrheiten schnell
entscheiden weil der evolution geht es
darum wie im beispiel mit dem löwen der
soll schnell entscheiden können der so
auf der sicheren seite sein
und da ist manchmal ein differenziertes
erfassen und war in wirklichkeit wie ein
hemmnis
deswegen baut uns diese revolution all
diese ungünstigen features in unser
programm heißt dass wir können die
wirklichkeit überhaupt nicht erkennen
ich würde sagen das potenzial ist da
also auch mit diesen flächen werkzeug
das wir haben mit diesem man kann sagen
das hat vor nachteile wie jedes programm
das hat seine box seine schwierigkeit
wenn man die kennt glaube ich kann man
das potenzial besser nutzen das
potenzial dazu ist da aber ich glaube
wir unterschätzen diese ganzen aus sicht
der aufklärung schwachstellen und
fehlerquellen die uns die evolution
darin den verstand eingenommen haben
schon gesagt wir bieten uns die welt zu
recht wird blenden dinge die nicht
passen wir vereinfachen gedenken in
schwarz und weiß was hinten so die die
prominentesten denkfehler die wir
menschen machen diejenigen häufigsten
vor
sie haben schon ein paar gesagt also
eins ist dass wir gerne stimmige
geschichten mögen also wir machen lieber
wir haben lieber eine runde geschichte
eine die unseren vorstellungen
entspricht wir kennen das vermeidung
kognitiver dissonanz menschen nehmen
gerne die informationen auf die ihre
eigene meinung bestätigen nicht die
denen widersprechen
man passt das an und bietet das so dass
sich ein stimmiges gesamtbild entwickelt
1 das einem entgegenkommt das stimmig
ist dann ist unser gehirn natürlich sagt
das immer so einen kausalen key unser
gehirn sucht sucht überall wie ein
drogenspürhund sucht nach wo ist eine
kausalität wo es ursache ist ursache und
wirkung und das gehirn ist sehr gut
darin ursachen wirkungen zu erkennen
aber das gehirn wird auch immer ursache
und wirkung irgendwo rein produzieren wo
das gar nicht vorhanden ist vielleicht
ein zufall im spiel ist wo man
vielleicht bestimmte faktoren nicht
berücksichtigt hat und nur dann stimmt
dass unser gehirn wird im zweifelsfall
sagen lieber eine ursache
wirkungsbeziehungen die mir vertraut ist
die für mich stimmlich ist als dass sie
richtig ist und da muss man die aussagen
so eine funktion von dem ist ja das gibt
uns das gute gefühl die welt verstanden
zu haben also das gefühl wir können das
kontrollieren eine eigentlich unsichere
welt wir können die verstehen und
kontrollieren es gibt ein
ich sage es eine kompetenz und kontrolle
überzeugung dass evolutionäre vorteile
was allah gott alles sehen ja auch in
allen studien dass die menschen die sich
tendenziell um realistische
selbsteinschätzung überschätzen
erfolgreicher sind
sie beziehen sich im ersten teil des
buches stark auf den psychologen und
träger des wirtschaftsnobelpreises
daniel kahneman und der hat ja in seinem
buch schnell aus und langsames denken
diese viele dieser denkfehler untersucht
empirisch und auch diesen sogenannten
anker effekt er ganz wichtig ist und was
das ist das hat er hier in dieser
sendung wie folgt erläutert wäre ganz
kurz an das lied nicht senkt damit komme
ich zum anker effekt ihre anderen frage
diesbezüglich gibt es eine interessante
studie aus deutschland die fritz strack
und seine studenten gemacht haben
ich glaube in würzburg bei dieser studie
geht es um folgendes zuerst frage ich
sie kostet ein deutsches auto
durchschnittlich mehr oder weniger als
200.000 schweizer franken und dann frage
ich sie
was ist der durchschnittliche preis
eines deutschen autors andere probanden
frage ich kostet ein deutsches auto
durchschnittlich mehr oder weniger als
15.000 schweizer franken
und dann frage ich sie nach dem
durchschnittlichen preise die beiden
gruppen schätzen nicht den gleichen
durchschnittspreis und zwar weil etwas
ähnliches passiert wie beim wenig
200.000 22 franken sage denken sie ein
mercedes ein teurer autos
wenn ich sie dann nach dem
durchschnittlichen preis frage kommen
ihnen teure autos in den sinn
beginne ich aber mit 15.000 schweizer
franken denken sie ein billiger autos
das ist der anker effekt ich setze ihnen
eine zahl in den kopf und beeinflusse
damit ihr denken und wenn ich diesen
effekt kenne bin ich dann geschützt vor
ihm
geschützt vielleicht nicht vollständig
geschützt aber ich glaube es ist immer
besser man kennt eine gefahr dass man
kennt sie nicht und läuft blind da rein
und dann kann man sich manchmal
überlegen und das noch mal überprüfen ob
es wirklich so ist wie man sich das
vorstellt es ist deswegen finde ich auch
diese ganzen mechanismen ich glaube es
ist gut wenn man die kennt das ist wie
eine gebrauchsanleitung für das gehirn
dass man weiß wie bei einem auto die
bremsen sind vielleicht nicht so gut
oder das licht nicht so gut und dann
kann man damit besser umgehen als wenn
man blind mit all diesen schwächen durch
die welt fährt als persönliche
strategien haben sie sich sich zu
schützen nicht in die falle zu gehen von
diesen denkfehler und verzerrungen
ich glaube es ist vorteilhaft wenn man
sie kennt und die psychologie und kann
man hat ja selbst sehr viel dazu
erforscht das man kennt ganz viele
solche muster typischen verzerrungen
dass der anker effekt ist einer von
denen
und ich glaube das ist schon von vorteil
wenn man das weiß dass das gehirn zum
beispiel nicht darauf ausgelegt ist mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten gut umzugehen man
kennt diesen effekt dass vielleicht
unbewusst sachen eingespielt werden
die man dann unbewusst verarbeitet und
urteile bringt ich schütze nicht
vollständig aber ich glaube es ist gut
wenn man das kennt und kann dann
vielleicht auch manchmal nachdenken
korrigieren oder etwas revidieren was
ich am anfang so total stimmig und gut
und richtig anfühlt das erhalten was sie
erzählen kommt bei mir ein bild hoch
nämlich dass der rosa brille durch die
wir die welt betrachten und es ist
scheint unmöglich zu sein in die welt zu
sehen ohne diese brille
also wir tragen die die ganze zeit
liegen uns die welt zurecht jetzt ist es
so in ihrem buch sagen sie es gibt
verschiedene ebenen sozusagen wie drei
brillen die wir eigentlich auf haben
das erste ist wenn wir etwas
registrieren wahrnehmen dann aber wenn
wir das positiv verarbeiten und am
schluss gibt es auch so etwas wie
generalisierung irgendwie ganz kurz
erläutern was diese drei ebenen bedeutet
also ich nenne das ja das rsg modell
registrieren
subjektivierung generalisieren hat ein
übergeordnetes modell und das bedeutet
zunächst mal nehmen wir irgendeine
information war die kann von außen
kommen die kann auch von innen kommen
das kann eine körperwahrnehmung sein
dass man irgendwas bewusst registriert
aber in dem moment wo es bewusst
registrieren wie sie sagen ist das schon
durch eine brille durchgegangen also das
ist am schluss kann man sagen das ist
unser betriebssystem wo so wie es
aufgebaut ist kann nur damit arbeiten
dass bestimmte voraussetzungen von
anfang an annimmt das ist das kann man
sagen kann sagt die wir haben nur mit
erscheinungen der dinge zu tun das ding
an sich ist schon erkennbar für uns also
über diese eintrittspforte kommen wir
nicht da komme gar nicht raus das ist
mit unseren betriebssystem gar nicht
anders machbar die erste brille
die haben wir sowieso auf dann
registrieren wir etwas also das ist die
phase des des registrieren
und jetzt findet ein prozess statt im
gehirn den nennig subjektivierung jetzt
sind all diese vielen hilfreichen
mechanismen am werk die die evolution
unserer eingebaut hat nach dem motto
finde eine kausalität egal ob sie da ist
oder nicht findet eine geschichte die
dir gut tut finde etwas was deine
überzeugung schon entspricht finde etwas
was dir selber gutmütig kompetent und
gut fühlst die gefühlte wahrheit schlägt
die differenziertere wir wollen schwarz
weiß wir wollen entweder oder freund
oder feind wir wollen nicht mal so mal
so alle diese mechanismen sind jetzt am
werk man kann sich das so vorstellen
registrieren
und jetzt wird das ich vergleiche das
mit einer backstube jetzt werden dauernd
große kekse kuchen krümel gebacken und
das ist ein prozess der an eigenen die
information mit so geformt dass sie gut
zu uns passt dass ihr wieso jemand der
sich an einer neuen kultur
integriert integrieren wie die
information so dass sie tun's stimmig
ist mit all den verzerrungen die dort
drin sein
und dann gibt es eine dritte stufe das
ist die dritte brille und das glaube ich
ist bis jetzt vielleicht zu wenig
beachtet und die haben die starke
tendenz wenn wir denn mal eine
überzeugung haben eine theorie eine
meinung dann haben wir die tendenz dass
zu generalisieren zu sagen das ist nicht
nur da sondern das ist generell das ist
die theorie die die welt erklärt das ist
die theorie die die menschen erklärt und
dann sind wir bei diesen überzeugungen
die so generalisierung führen
das klassische beispiel sind wenn wir
mal eine regel haben eine ordnung
irgendetwas dann neigen wir dazu die bis
ins absurde zu generalisieren und auf
alles und jedes anzuwenden was nicht bei
drei auf dem baum kommt der forschung
reduktionismus euro oder dass man sagt
letztlich geht es immer nur darum
man hat dann eine theorie für alles und
das sieht die einzelnen abweichungen
differenzierungen nicht mehr
aber jetzt kann man sagen okay das ist
bei allen menschen so gibt es denn auch
sozusagen persönlichkeit abhängige
verzerrungen also verzehren sie die welt
anders aus ich ja selbstverständlich
jeder mensch verzerrt ist anders und da
gibt es es gibt sozusagen wenn wir das
noch mal sagen es gibt die erste stufe
das ist wir haben die brille auf unser
betriebssystem gestattet uns gar nicht
außerhalb der brille wahrzunehmen der
zweiten machen wir nach dem rsg modells
objektivieren wir alles und passen das
an verzerren das da und dann gibt es
persönlichkeitsprofile die diese
verzerrung besonders ausgeprägt
praktizieren was denken sie an
verschwörungstheoretiker zum beispiel
das sind vielleicht menschen die die
welt ganz grundsätzlich aufgrund ihrer
persönlichkeit ganz grundsätzlich
feindlich und bedrohlich erleben und die
werden jetzt informationen dauernd so
verarbeiten und sagen das passt wieder
zu meiner verschwörungstheorie das
brauche ich ein baue ich ein
das heißt die steigern diese mechanismen
die sowieso schon da sind bei allen
menschen steigern die noch mal
individuell sehr stark und verzerren und
verdrehen und generalisieren in noch
viel ausgeprägtere maße als das der
normal verzerrte menschen sind natürlich
verzerren sie die wert
so ich glaube in normalem mal spektrum
wie das andere auch und sie haben das
schon angesprochen die strategie damit
umzugehen ist ja dass man versucht sich
dieser gefahr bewusst zu sein und dann
nochmal prüft und nochmal gegen checkt
und nicht dem spontanen gefühl was ist
so toll anfühlt und wo man sich selber
so gut damit fühlt dem zu vertrauen
sondern dem generell etwas zu misstrauen
wenn wir über persönlichkeiten reden
dann scheint mir so dass es ganz grob
gesagt er soll sich die egoistischen
persönlichkeiten gibt denen die
selbstbehauptung sehr wichtig ist und
andere die erde teamplayer sind jetzt
tourismuskooperation sie haben ganz am
anfang der sender gesagt die
gefährlichen eigenschaften und haben den
egoismus erwähnt wie was war dann
evolutionär betrachtet da ich hilfe
reiche ein egoist zu sein oder ein
teamplayer
ja es kommt auf die situation an aber
generell ist es ja so wir haben jetzt
über die vernunft über sozusagen die
dass das werkzeug des menschen
gesprochen wo die evolutionären
schwachstellen da drin sind das ganze
spielt sich ab in einem großen
evolutionären zusammenhanglos zwei pole
gibt das eine ist die egoistische
skrupellose selbstbehauptung ich ich ich
und ich muss sehen dass ich überlebe
das ist das wo ich sage was nietzsche so
schön bezeichnet hat als willen zur
macht das ist dieses unersetzliche
dieses grenzenlose diese weiter weiter
weiter immer mehr immer höher immer
schneller
die das ist ein evolutionärer triebfeder
und die zweite ist das kooperations
potenzial
man kann dass egoismus nennt man kann
sagen dass es die zusammenarbeit mit
anderen und beides hat vor und nachteile
beides hat vor und nachteile und in
zwischen diesen beiden polen ist die
menschliche psyche aufgespannt und jetzt
gibt es menschen die ganz stark auf
dieser egoistischen seite sind und den
kooperation egal die sind dann
persönlichkeitsprofile die skrupellos
sind die andere menschen missachten dem
bedürfnis egal sind das ist so in
reinform das was als revolutionärer pohl
sowieso vorhanden ist bei allen menschen
aber dann hat sie auf dieser einen seite
ist und sie sagen es mit recht es gibt
menschen die dann sehr stark auf dieser
kooperation seite sind und sehr starken
was ist für die anderen gut im
extremfall sind es menschen die sich
total unterordnen anderen personen und
die ohne die entscheidung anderer gar
nicht mehr an eine entscheidung treffen
können das sind wie die extrem typen die
meisten menschen bewegen sich irgendwo
in der mitte zwischen diesen beiden
polen
man könnte sagen die kooperation kann
eine strategie sein um selbst gut zu
überlegen als absolut ins der
selbstbehalt also absolut die
entwicklung des menschen ist ein
beispiel dafür
man nimmt ja an dass gerade diese
kooperationsfähigkeit beim homo sapiens
der dann gruppen von 100 oder 120
organisieren konnten ein wichtiger
evolutionärer vorteil war aber sind wie
zwei seiten der gleichen medaille
revolution ist es so breites dient der
überlebens und reproduktionsfähigkeit
man sieht schon sie kennen sozusagen die
schwächen und schattenseiten des
menschen sehr gut haben die lange auch
erforscht
auch die abgründe haben sich mit sexual
und gewaltstraftätern beschäftigt waren
von 1997 bis 2018 haben sie den
psychiatrisch psychologischen dienst des
kantons zürich geleitet im amt für
justizvollzug und waren maßgeblich
beteiligt kann man sagen an einer
neuausrichtung der der justiz und des
strafvollzugs und angefangen hat das
ganze mit einem mordfall 19 93 1993
erschütterte ein mordfall die schweiz
ein sexualstraftäter im hafturlaub
tötete die 20 jährige pascal brumann am
zollikerberg bei zürich
der täter war kein unbekannter er hatte
bereits elf vergewaltigungen und zwei
sexualmorde begangen
dennoch durfte er auf unbegleiteten
hafturlaub
dieser mord löste ein radikales umdenken
im umgang mit sexualstraftätern aus es
kam zu tiefgreifenden reformen in justiz
und strafvollzug
neu war die erkenntnis dass es menschen
gibt vor denen man die gesellschaft
dauerhaft schützen muss dafür brauchte
es neue maßnahmen der gut 30 jährige
psychiater frank urbaniok leitete die
wichtigsten davon 1
das sind täter da geht es nicht um
behandlung um das risiko zu senken das
zu tun wäre
therapeutischer größenwahn und das wäre
gefährlich da geht es darum das klar zu
erkennen dass zu deklarieren und zu
vollziehen und auch lebenslang zu
vollziehen
wir werden das auch in anderen
gesichtspunkten machen das schließt das
nicht aus aber hier geht die sicherheit
der bevölkerung vor
frank urbaniok arbeitete mit einem neuen
delikt orientierten ansatz
er entwickelte eine methode die die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines rückfalls von
sexualstraftätern möglichst genau
voraussagen sollen das war neu und
polarisierte urbaniok erkannte dass sich
via medien die öffentliche meinung und
politische prozesse beeinflussen lassen
[Applaus]
diskutieren mit dem bekannt ist
psychiater von der schweiz frank
urbaniok frank urbaniok professor für
forensische psychiatrie und unterstützt
mit seiner arbeit justiz und polizei er
wurde der bekannteste und
einflussreichste gerichtspsychiater der
schweiz ebenso erfolgreich wie
umstritten
mehr als 20 jahre lang führte er als
chefarzt den psychiatrisch
psychologischen dienst des kantons
zürich
ja und umstritten waren sie auch
deswegen weil es ja ein forensisches
therapie und risiko evolution system
entwickelt haben mit dem man berechnen
kann wie wahrscheinlich es ist dass ein
straftäter rückfällig wird und hardliner
bezeichneten sie dann als wegsperren der
nation weil man die reise gesagt man
müsse die bevölkerung vor diesen tätern
schützen dazwischen psychiater mario gyr
warf ihn sogar zitat eine statistische
menschen vermessung der überlauf vor und
der rechtsanwalt mathias brunner meinte
die psychiatrie sei einfach nicht in der
lage eine delikt prognose zu stellen ist
denn der mensch berechenbarer als wir
meinen als er sich
also man muss sich zunächst folgendes
bewusst machen dass wir alle menschen in
kontinuitäten leben wir haben prägnante
persönlichkeitseigenschaften die uns
prägen die uns kennzeichnen
das gilt nicht nur für straftäter das
gilt generell für menschen und sie
werden wahrscheinlich den meisten
menschen werden sie zwei oder drei
eigenschaften finden von denen sie sagen
die sind relativ typisch und prägnant
für diese personen das kann sich um was
ganz unproblematisches handeln wie zum
beispiel sehr ordnungsliebender sehr
perfektionistisch und wenn es einen
menschen zum beispiel seine eigenschaft
hat die prägend ist zum beispiel
ordnungsliebe dann drückt dienst
verhalten durch ein mensch der sehr
ordentlich ist die wenn sie erkennen
weil sie wissen der staat seine
handtücher mit dem lineal gemessen
übereinander und der muss fünfmal
kontrollieren bevor die tür verlässt
wird die abgeschlossen hat und so ist es
generell mit prägnanten eigenschaften
prägnante eigenschaften sind
charakteristisch für eine person und sie
drücken das verhalten durch sie tun dass
eher früher als später
und sie verändern sich kaum oder gar
nicht also der sehr sehr ordentliche
mensch sind super ordentlicher mensch
der wird nicht eines tages morgens
aufwachen und sagen jetzt war ich war
ich 20 jahre super ordentlich das ist
mir zu anstrengend jetzt gehe ich aufs
gegenteil und bin an messi
sondern der wird vielleicht mit seiner
eigenschaft anders umgehen aber diese
eigenschaften haben eine hohe
kontinuität weil entstehen diese
eigenschaften hin eine früh in der
kindheit verfestigen sich in der jugend
und prägnante eigenschaften
da reden wir von zwei oder drei
eigenschaften die drücken stark ins
verhalten durch und prägen das fahrrad
deswegen kann man sie auch im verhalten
sehen
bei straftätern ist das genauso und da
ist die suche nach sozusagen
risikorelevanten eigenschaften also
jemand der auf kinder steht wenn der das
so empfindet dann wird das und das ist
eine prägnante eigenschaft dann hat er
eine höhere wahrscheinlichkeit
übergriffe auf kinder zu verüben das
liegt auf der hand
und eigentlich wenn wir risiko
kalkulationen machen dann machen wir
nichts anderes als dass wir nach diesem
prägnanten eigenschaften die mit risiken
zu tun haben suchen und das kann jeder
mensch glaube ich in seinem alter kann
das gut nachvollziehen wenn sie mit
menschen menschen die sie sehr gut
kennen und lebenspartner zum beispiel
dann können sie relativ gut
prognostizieren was der in bestimmten
situationen machen wird
warum können sie das war sie in der
regel der den menschen denen sie gut
kennen mit dem sie zusammen leben die
kennen sie meistens gut und sie wissen
wie der sich früher in entsprechenden
situationen verhalten hat diese beiden
komponenten im bogen machen nichts
anderes aus denen kann man relativ gut
sagen was ist wahrscheinliches und was
ist unwahrscheinlich dass gewalt
einsätze gelangt aber da ist ja immer
noch frei die person ist eine noch
feiern kann sich immer noch anders
entscheiden obwohl es unwahrscheinlich
ist und sie deswegen wegzusperren
ihr habt den weg sparen reden wir ja gar
nicht das ist ja finde ich so ein
bisschen ein fast undifferenzierte
propaganda weil mir geht es ja gar nicht
also die frage was ist die folge davon
das ist ja eine ganz andere das muss ein
gericht entscheiden stellvertretend für
das gericht also für die gesellschaft
aber die aufgabe des forensischen gut
auch das ist dass man die persönlichkeit
so gut wie möglich und differenziert wie
möglich beschreibt und abbildet und dann
sagt was sind hier wahrscheinlich
unwahrscheinliche verhaltensweisen wie
ihm ein mensch der impulsiv ist der
schon zehnmal teller an die wand
geschmissen hat dann werden sie sagen es
ist wahrscheinlicher ist ein elftes mal
tot als dass jemand der aggression total
nach innen wendet und aggression scam
dies und das geht es und die das
missverständnis was das von ihnen
angesprochene system fortress angeht ist
dass es geht hier nicht um einen
abstrakten algorithmus darum irgendwas
zu berechnen sondern es geht schlicht
und allein darum dass krankheitsbezogene
diagnosesysteme nicht dafür gemacht sind
risiken zu erkennen sind dafür gemacht
um störungen psychiatrische störungen zu
erkennen oder krankheiten und deswegen
macht fotos folgendes es gibt in fotos
100 mehr als 100 risiko eigenschaften
die halt riskant sein können und es geht
darum dass man diesen 100 risiko
eigenschaften dieses risiko profil einer
person so gut wie möglich abbildet in
dem man erkennt was sind die prägnanten
eigenschaft was sind die zwei drei
eigenschaften dieser person wie
ausgeprägt sind die das legt man da und
dann ist das gericht am zug zu sagen was
sind maßnahmen die daraus folgen und
dass jemand dann lebenslang weggesperrt
wird das ist die kleinste gruppe ist ein
ganz ganz kleine gruppe da finde ich
auch richtig dass man das tut
in vielen fällen müssen sie gar nichts
man das risiko klein ist in manchen
vielen weiteren fällen müssen sie wenig
tun weil sie sagen ich nehme die waffe
weg ich kontrolliere alkohol drogen das
reicht dann sind sie bei vielen bei
spezifischen therapien und ganz erst am
ende sind sie bei der kleinen gruppe der
lebenslang zu verwahren denn weil sie
extrem gefährlich und teuer und und um
behandelbar sind
und auch bei dem phänomen geht es
sozusagen darum differenzieren es gibt
dass es gibt dass es gibt dass es gibt
das und es gibt nicht nur schwarz weiß
entweder oder den einzelfall genau
abbilden den einzelfall genau erkennen
und dann eine verhältnismäßige maßnahme
dafür finden wofür die gerichte
zuständig sind
was verstehen sie unter der mast
freiheit dort ein finanz freiheit gibt
es so was ich bin davon überzeugt dass
ist das geht weil das für mich die viel
plausiblere annahmen ist wie das
universum wie das strukturiert ist man
kann sich das so vorstellen wie ein
stein das gesagt hat mit dem urknall ist
alles vorherbestimmt
aber ich mag das gesetz ist ein
naturgesetz man kann sich überlegen ist
ein universum ist ein findet man es
plausibler dass alles vorherbestimmt ist
vom ersten von der ersten sekunde an
oder glaubt man dass es sozusagen beides
ist eine vor strukturierung und dann
eine möglichkeit für varianz für
flexibilität und ist eine glaubensfrage
dass eine glaubensfrage am schloss ist
keine die man empirisch beweisen können
oder widerlegen kann aber ich glaube das
effektivere ist wenn man eine kombi
macht aus beiden wie das bei den beim
menschen auch ist bestimmte
wasserschadens wir sind wahrscheinlich
anders und unwahrscheinlicher
aber ja wir haben es fast nie mit nun
oder 100% zu tun sondern mit irgendwas
zwischendrin das glaube ich fürs
universum auch in ihrer biografie gibt
seinen kasten einschnitten bis 2016
haben sie sich zurückgezogen
aus diesem amt für justizvollzug
aufgrund einer bauchspeicheldrüsen
erkrankung
und sie hatten eine die ärzte hatten ihn
eine erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit von fünf
prozent zugesichert
sie sagten der ganze prozess sei die
hölle gewesen
was hat diese hölle welche spuren hat
diese höhere hinterlassen in einigen
gutes hat zunächst mal vor allem eine
ganz entscheidende änderung in meinem
leben bedeutet
ich führe heute ein ganz anderes leben
als zuvor
das ist ein sie sagen es eine ganz
dramatische zäsur in meinem leben ich
würde aber nicht sagen dass ich dadurch
fundamental neue erkenntnis bekommen
habe ich sagen wir mal ich habe die
dinge die ich gut kann konnte ich dann
noch gut und die ich nicht gut konnte
oder nicht gut kann konnte ich dann auch
nicht gut es ist auch nicht eine
überraschung gewesen dass so etwas
passieren können sondern das hat mich
getroffen das trifft viele andere
menschen auch es ist etwas was im leben
passieren kann und so habe ich das auch
genommen und
selbstverständlich ist eine sehr
prägende erfahrungen ein großer
einschnitt aber ich habe nicht das
gefühl dass ich heute ein anderer mensch
als der der ich vorher obwohl sie jetzt
mit dieser angst hatte ich leben müssen
naja aber von einem rückfall ja mit dem
muss ich leben das macht das leben
anders das führt dazu dass zb wenn es
wieder untersuchungen gibt dass das
leben sich verlangsamt einen moment und
dann geht es wieder weiter
das ist eine andere grund
ausgangsbedingungen in verschärfter form
kann man sagen ist es aber das
eigentlich was im leben sowieso immer
vorhanden ist dass man zum leben die
möglichkeit des todes dazugehört sie
wirken hat mich sehr diszipliniert sehr
leistungsorientiert dass menschen die
arbeiten er heute immer noch
verhältnismäßig viel was treibt sie
eigentlich an
ja ich arbeite heute sehr viel weniger
als früher
ja das hat sich total geändert und die
balance zwischen freizeit und zwischen
sie arbeite die hat sich komplett
verändert ganz anders als vorher aber
generell glaube ich bin ich eine person
die gerne irgendwas macht gegangen das
macht die sich gedanken macht die
versucht dinge zu durchdenken dinge zu
machen
ich liebe es wenn sachen funktionieren
mich interessiert die praxis mich
interessiert etwas zu machen was etwas
verbessert das ist sicher etwas
was für mich ein großer antrieb ist in
einem interview haben sie mal gesagt das
ist die existenzielle unzufriedenheit
die sie antreibt ich bin kein
zufriedenheit ist nicht meine stärke und
es ist dann eher so wenn nicht etwas
gemacht habe dann bin ich dann halt
wieder bei dem nächsten was kann man
noch machen was kann man noch besser
machen
das glaube ich ist in der tat vielleicht
ein prägnanter persönlichkeit zug
was ist das schwierigste am menschsein
für sie das schwierigste
ich finde es schwierig viele dinge zu
sehen auf der welt von denen ich in
meiner subjektiv verzerrten perspektive
sage die finde ich unmöglich
die finde ich dürften so nicht sein und
da könnte das plakativ sagen das reicht
von kriegen über misshandlungen von
menschen über respektlosigkeit über
menschen die betrogen werden über
umweltzerstörung umgang mit dem planeten
und mit anderen lebewesen und was ich
sagen will was ist das ist für mich so
generell das schwierigste und auch zu
wissen da kann man kann nichts tun
nichts würde ich nie sagen nein
überhaupt nicht aber man kann das ist
ein
es ist ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
klingt so wie nichts das wäre mir zu
wenig aber es ist ganz klar man kann was
kleines in seinem eigenen umfeld tun und
dann hoffen dass das irgendwann mehr
menschen so sehen das ist irgendwie sich
dann insgesamt ändert aber ich würde nie
sagen man kann nichts tun und dann immer
fast immer was tun
seit ihrer studienzeit boxen sie
meistens gegen boxsäcke wir haben hier
ein paar bilder an nach vorbereitet
entscheiden uns dass man wie das
aussieht weiß ich dass gegen block 6
wenn ich das so sehe stellt sich bei mir
unweigerlich die frage nach dem kopfkino
gegen ihn boxen sie gegen wen haben sie
schon aus geboxt im kopf ja nicht nur im
kopf also es ist ich muss dazu sagen
weil das ist auch durch diesen
dokumentarfilm ist das dann sehr
prominent geworden ich bin generell ein
mensch der sich gerne bewegt
die herausforderung lag und der auch so
die kann man sagen dass sich
beanspruchen leistung mag daran spaß hat
aber das alles ist natürlich absolut in
einem hobby und amateurbereich und da
gibt es mehrere da gibt es fußball da
gibt es laufen da gibt's boxen da gibt's
ja und ich habe mal dass eine intensive
getan das andere aber ich habe mich
immer für zu wenig talentiert gefühlt um
das richtig gut zu können deswegen bin
ich auch psychiater und profisportler
trotzdem die frage nach den wahren
wer ist bei ihnen den kopf ich habe eine
zeitlang auch geboxt studium so ein
bisschen hobbymäßig und ich hab mich
jetzt hab ich stelle mir machen nach
gegen mich selbst zum beispiel ja ich
habe keine das stelle ich mir das stelle
ich mir nie worden und das stellen wir
wirklich nicht vor es ist auch glaube
ich nicht ein ventil für um geärgert und
dann musste ich sonst im leben habt
sondern es ist dann er so ich versuche
das besser zu machen und an die
leistungsgrenzen die leistungsgrenze ich
mit meinem trainer was technisch nicht
gut ist was man verbessern kann das
kommen ja auch wie alles ewig verbessern
und das ist mir die optik dann im
zweiten teil der sendung noch ein
bisschen über die gesellschaftlichen
folgen sprechen dieser unvernunft könnte
man sagen oder dieser schwächen der
vernunft und das eine ist eher
überraschend sie sagen die gegenwärtige
krise der demokratie also populismus zum
beispiel neue autokraten das hat auch
damit zu tun mit dieser evolution
evolutionären geschichte der vernunft
und mit ihren schwächen
das müssten sie erläutern also ich sehe
ist grundsätzlich so dass in allen
phänomen und dem wir zu tun haben in
gesellschaften in unternehmen in
medien über all das hat eigentlich meine
menschen zu tun und ich finde fast der
faktor ist so wenig berücksichtigt weil
ich aus meiner sicht sehe ich ähnliche
phänomene in unterschiedlichen bereichen
weil das jemandem menschen zu tun hatten
also meine these ist diese evolutionären
schwachstellen des menschen die drücken
durch in irgendeiner theorie in einem
glauben in den medien in der politik in
der ökonomie und das versuche ich ein
buch wie ein bisschen durchzudeklinieren
weil immer der mensch drin steckt man
sieht das ja auch ganz schön wenn man
extremistische ideologien sich ansieht
wie können komplett unterschiedliche
ideen haben und dann im konkreten was
mit den menschen passiert sieht das dann
versucht ähnlich aus und ich glaube da
drücken immer ähnliche mechanismen quasi
das des menschen durch was den
populismus angeht oder den extremismus
ich finde das eine sehr
besorgniserregende entwicklung dass das
modell der demokratie oder um mit popper
zu sprechen dass der offenen
gesellschaften dass das seit jahren
unter druck ist und weltweit auf dem
rückzug das finde ich besorgniserregend
und nun versteht man es ja häufig so
dass man sagt ja diese strömung kommen
auch weil die vereinfachen weil die
populistisch und extremistisch agieren
das stimmt die nutzen wenn man so will
extremistische propaganda methoden die
extrem auf die vereinfachung setzen
extrem auf diese schwachstellen des
evolutionären der evolutionären vernunft
und die bewirtschaften die skrupellos
das ist ein teil des erfolgs ich sage
aber umgekehrt
es gibt auch hausaufgaben die vor allem
die westlichen demokratien machen müssen
weil sie selber sich so
selbstverständlich auf der guten und
korrekten seite erleben und
gar nicht sehen was sie vielleicht
selber für schwachstellen aufbauen
auch mit verzerrungen und tabuisierung
ich glaube die westlichen demokratien
schaffen angriffsflächen schaffen
angriffs verheimlicht
wenn man die wahl von kramp sieht dann
glaube ich dass viele menschen auch von
den durchgestylten parolen von den in
hinterzimmern ausgeklammerten pr
strategien von den glatten politiker
statements viele einfach die nase voll
haben und die alternative ist eine
schlechte alternative trump hat etwas
kann man sagen er artig verrücktes an
sich der liegt völlig hemmungslos
aber was man ihm wahrscheinlich nicht
unterstellen wird ist dass das der so
ist wie man ihn sieht der ist
authentisch und das glaube ich ist ein
besorgniserregendes symptom das
vielleicht verrücktheit der manche
menschen der einzige garant dafür ist
der ist wenig echt den spürt man als
mensch das ist eine deswegen sagt sagte
mich auch der heißeste die politik hat
jahrzehntelange fehler gemacht dass sie
zu künstlich war
ich finde sie ist so künstlich sie ich
so durchgestylt im sinne von man weiß
genau was kann man sagen was kann man
nicht sagen was kommt gut an was kommt
nicht gut an
es werden
manchmal phrasen bedient die dann
einfach sich gut anfühlen aber die in
der realität gar nicht umsetzbar sind
und in diese löcher in diese
zwischenräume können populisten
extremisten rein grätschen und können
themen aufkommen die in der ich würde
sagen in der offiziellen auch medien und
diskussionskultur unterbelichtet
vorkommen er ist eigentlich dass sie
sagen die demokratie schadet sich mit
tabuisierung kritisieren da wirklich
auch die medien und nennen das beispiel
ausländerkriminalität also da werde
irgendwie tabuisiert vertuscht fakten
verdreht weil sie unangenehm sind und
vielleicht nicht ins weltbild der
journalistinnen und journalisten passend
sie sprechen sogar von gezielter
desinformation und von weicher zensur
das klingt für mich fast nach lügen
presse ja ich habe dem begriff lügen
presse bewusst vermieden was ich mit
weicher zensur meine das ist nicht eine
zensurbehörde die wie vielleicht in
china oben dran ist und vorgaben macht
und sagt ihr müsst das schreiben das
dürfte nicht schreiben es ist vielleicht
eine selbstverpflichtung indem man und
ausländerkriminalität ist ein gutes
gutes beispiel dafür
ich glaube man hat das ehrenwerte motiv
man will nicht rassismus befeuern
und das ist ja total richtig dass man
das macht und aus dem heraus glaube ich
kommt es oft zu einer haltung dass man
sagt das könnten die leute missverstehen
deswegen gehen wir damit anders um und
da finde ich fängt das problem an es
gibt ein vielleicht ehren wird das motiv
führt am schluss aber trotzdem zu einer
verzerrung man kann das am thema
ausländerkriminalität ganz gut zeigen
es gibt bestimmte es gibt phänomene in
der ausländerkriminalität wo bestimmte
kann man auch sagen nationalitäten stark
überrepräsentiert sind bei der
kriminalität ok jetzt gibt zum beispiel
der offiziellen diskussionen gibt es
sechs argumente ins feld geführt werden
und mit denen man sagt ja die zahlen
sind zwar so aber eigentlich sind die
zahlen falsch das phänomen dahinter ist
ein anderes das hat gar nichts damit zu
tun dass erklärt sich über anderen
beispiel ist
ein argument was seit 20 jahren durch
die medien durch die talkshows geistert
ist dass gesagt wird er ausländer werden
halt häufiger angezeigt als deutsche zum
beispiel und da das erklärt die hohen
zahl was also ist der faktor aber das
ist wissenschaftlich umstritten ob das
so ist das ist nur in teilbereichen so
aber ein argument ist ein ganz anderes
wenn man das anführt da müsste man sagen
wenn das stimmt dann müsste es bei den
verurteilungen anders aussehen
da müsste es bei den strafgefangenen
anders aussehen tut es aber nicht
ein anderes noch schlagendes argument
und dann bin ich wieder bei den medien
ist jeder weiß aus dem tatort und aus
dem krimi weiß der schon einen tatort
gesehen hat weiß wenn da eine leiche
liegt es klingelt dann fährt der
kommissar losen fängt an zu ermitteln
da brauchst keine anzeige er braucht
nicht weil es gibt delikte muss gar
keine anzeige braucht und ich wundere
mich warum seit 20 jahren kein einziger
journalist auf dieses argument mal
zurück fragt unser dann müsste es beim
morden ja anders aussehen wenn das
stimmt morgen sieht es auch noch viel
schlechter aus und das kleine beispiel
zeigt aus meiner sicht dass man ich
finde dann mit bequemen argumenten die
scheinbar ungefährlich sind oder die
vielleicht einem durchaus ehrenwerten
ziel entsprechen kommt man besser durch
und hinterfragt dadurch und das glaube
ich ist ein problem weil wenn man das
letztlich bagatellisiert und wenn man
das in abrede stellt dann greifen sich
populisten und extremisten und andere
trübe gestalten greifen sich das thema
und dann nutzen sie das
instrumentalisieren sie das
bewirtschaften das thema und dann mit
den
mit den wirklich schlimmen aspekten von
auch fremdenfeindlichkeit und so weiter
und da glaube ich tut sich die
demokratie demokratie keinen gefallen
wenn sie solche heiklen themen den
populisten extremisten überlässt aber
was hat das mit dieser revolutionären
vernunft zu tun man will ja eher sagen
eigentlich wäre die schnelle intuitive
antwort die die fremden sind die bösen
so das hat uns irgendwie geschützt und
jetzt ist es aber bei ihm geht es um
politik und correctness um diese
vorsichtsmaßnahmen dass man das sonst
formuliert keine falschen vorurteilen
irgendwie bestehe kein rassismus
ja ich halte das so ist es ist ja auch
eine kann man sagen auch ja stimme ich
mit der mit der grundausrichtung dass
man sagt man will nicht rassismus
fördern
was muss noch mal ganz klar zu sagen ein
wichtiges und richtiges ziel ist
selbstverständlich aber die methode die
man anwendet dass man sagt ja dann ist
es vielleicht besser wir sagen das
phänomen gibt es gar nicht und wir
drehen das irgendwie ab oder wir reden
dass klein
ich sage die methode ist die falsche
methode und man hat die leute das spüren
weil bestimmte leute oder relevante
teile der bevölkerung das spüren und das
führt zu einem vertrauensverlust
das führt zu einem vertrauensverlust und
damit verliert demokratie oder verlieren
die etablierten kräfte in der demokratie
verlieren glaubwürdigkeit und sind
dadurch angreifbar für die hetzer
rassisten und populisten und extremisten
die dankbar diese themen nehmen und dann
natürlich ins absurde übersteigern aber
sind oft themen die einen berechtigten
kern haben nicht immer nicht immer aber
oft berechtigten kern die von der
offiziellen diskussions und medienkultur
liegen gelassen werden und ich würde
sagen nicht liegen lassen sondern ich
will vernünftige menschen die sich mit
diesen problemen beschäftigen und die
auch versuchen einer lösung zuzuführen
man muss da auch immer sagen sofort weil
man ausländerkriminalität die meisten
ausländer sind nicht kriminell halten
sich an regeln sind korrekt und man tut
auch denen keinen gefallen wenn man die
die probleme in diesem bereich
kleinredet den tut man gerade auch gar
keinen gefallen damit auch wenn ich mit
mit entsprechen personen reden das ist
gar kein problem mit denen das zu
besprechen weil die wissen das aber
konkret heißt das man entweder den
nationalitäten bei straftaten
ich finde man sollte die bevölkerung
transparent informieren darüber
man sollte sie transparent informieren
um die probleme dann auch entsprechend
angehen zu können die es gibt gegen eine
kleine gruppe betreffen
aber wenn man das wenn man das auch in
den statistiken gar nicht ausweist wenn
man das sozusagen mit argumenten sagt
das stimmt gar nicht die zahlen sind
falsch
das halte ich für die falsche strategie
da ist die vernunft der großen
bevölkerung klug und differenziert genug
in diesem fall dass man die wahrheit den
zumuten kann
ich glaube dass generell das ist eine
ganz wichtige frage zu stellen
ich bin generell auf der seite und sage
ich glaube die wahrheit oder die
wirklichkeit aus irgendwelchen gründen
weil es bequemer ist weil man die
befürchtung hat menschen verstehen das
nicht vertragen das nicht ich halte das
ich würde nie für eine gute strategie
langfristig das ist widerspricht auch
dem kern des verständnisses den wir von
offenen demokratischen diskurs haben von
austausch von argumenten und dann
versuchen gute lösungen zu finden dem
widerspricht es natürlich fundamental
wenn man versucht das vorher abzubiegen
muss vielleicht noch sagen dass wirklich
eine debatte natürlich auch darüber sie
vertreten jetzt eine position
aber es gibt natürlich auch das
bundesamt für politische bildung zum
beispiel bringt alle diese
gegenargumente weiterhin kräften die im
buch ich lasse das einfach mal so stehen
und möchte auch betonen dass sie eine
seite vertreten aber es die anderen
natürlich in der in der mehrheit ist und
wir haben wir dafür dass die menschen
sich selber eine meinung will genau ein
zweites thema das mich überrascht hat
wegen in sachen probleme also neben der
demokratie ist die bürokratie wo sie
sagen es herrscht überregulierung in
unserer zeit in unserer welt
verrechtlichung tendenzen bürokratie
überschüsse usw da habe ich mich gefragt
stimmt das wirklich und ist denn das so
schlimm
ja ich finde das schlimm und ich glaube
viele das ist ja auch nichts neues gibt
ja viele menschen die über bürokratie
stöhnen und ich glaube man kann sich das
schnell klar machen wenn man heute ein
größeres bauprojekt hat dann sind dann
haben wir zeit von 10 20 jahren dann
sind juristen sehr wichtig da drin
wir haben überall haben wir standards
controlling dinge wir haben bei wenn sie
heute bewerbungen haben dann gibt es
steak auf die art irgendwelche
algorithmen die das ausrechnen kriterien
also ich finde wir finden überall finden
an allen ecken und enden regulierungen
regulierung noch eine ordnung noch eine
regel noch eine noch eine ordnung und
ich glaube das entspringt am schluss
diesen darüber gesprochen dieser
evolutionären tendenz regeln und ordnung
zu generalisieren bis ins absurde zu
steigern
es gibt irgendwann den umkehrpunkt wohne
regel ich bin nicht gegen regeln und
ordnung sind wichtig strafrecht ist
wichtig viele anderen regeln sind
wichtig aber ich glaube man muss
sensibel auf den punkt gucken wo das
überdreht wird und wo der punkt kommt
dass es in vielen bereichen mehr schadet
als das nutzt
und da gibt es aus meiner sicht sehr
viele bereiche in der gesellschaft die
an der regel dichte an der weiteren
regulierung drohen zu ersticken
zwei beispiele nationen gehen sie ins
gesundheitssystem und gucken sie sich
die zeit an die für dokumentationen
verwendet werden müssen die sich
menschen an schreibtischen ausgedacht
haben die weggehen von patienten
datenschutz ist ein wichtiges thema aber
ich fürchte das wird zu einem
bürokratiemonster ausgebaut indem man
sich nämlich auf dinge konzentriert das
noch regelt und das noch regelt das noch
regelt dass es dann am schluss
eigentlich von der problemlösung weit
entfernt ist aber für viele viele
menschen völlig absurde
reglementierungen diese regelungen haben
ja in der regel ein zweck im einzel und
vernünftigen grund warum wir das 1 40
selbst haben ja auch so eine therapie
und risiko evaluations system er kreiert
und kriterienkataloge hätte man auch
sagen können
man kann lässt einfach die reinen
freiheit die anderen nicht ja ich bin
für strukturierte entscheidung und ich
bin dafür dass man differenziert dinge
wahrnimmt und weil man regelsystem jetzt
glaube ich jemanden 50 milliarden
möglichkeiten also es ist nicht das ist
nicht sehr engen reguliert es gibt viel
spielraum für die individuelle
kreativität aber den punkt um den den es
mir dabei geht immer wenn sie eine regel
wenn sie irgendwas berechtigt das finden
wo sie sagen da mache ich eine regel
macht eine ordnung dann finden sie
automatisch in dem prozess fünf sachen
die mit der gleichen berechtigung
auch geregelt werden müssten das heißt
um sie weiter sie gehen weitet sich das
exponentiell immer weiter aus und die
klage dass wir zu viel bürokratie haben
dass das haben ja viele da bin ich nicht
allein und ich glaube es hat etwas mit
kann man sagen zwiespältigkeit zu tun
wir werden darüber klagen würde es gibt
soviel gesetzt es gibt so viel
bürokratie und zu viele regeln und der
erste mensch der streit am gartenzaun
mit seinem nachbar hat und der irgendwas
findet wo er sagt das ist noch nicht
geregelt da gibts noch kein gesetz dafür
der forderten gesetz das erste liegen
was in den medien kommt wo man sagt da
ist irgendwas passiert es hat gar keine
richtigen dafür gegeben kein gesetz da
ist eine gewisse schizophrenie hat das
auch mit diesem vertrauensverlust zu tun
denen sie jetzt beim medien
diagnostiziert haben mit einer gewissen
angst vielleicht auch diese sehnsucht
kontrolle und nach regeln oder ist das
eher ein sonst selbst leid ich glaube es
ist ein selbstläufer weil sie sagen
zurecht er spricht natürlich in extremer
weise dem kontroll und ordnungs
bedürfnis das gibt uns ein gefühl der
sicherheit die regel die ordnung das
standardisierte gibt uns das zertifikat
das gibt uns eine sicherheit und ich
finde dieses system das ist der gute
teil daran aber es ist die gefahr dass
man das überdreht und dadurch regeln
immer weiter steigert bis in eine
absurdität kann ich im beispiel noch
dazu sagen ja gerne nach 1 ich zweifle
daran dass man quasi diese
regelungsdichte und diese bürokratien
und dass man die quasi von außen
regulieren können so nicht glauben muss
inseln setzen wo man das system sprengt
ich gebe ihm beispiel nation
wenn sie heute eine versicherung
abschließen gegen fahrraddiebstahl dann
sagt die versicherung ihnen sie sind
versichert dagegen dass ihnen das
fahrrad gestohlen wird
jetzt sagen sie haben nicht zu 100
prozent versichert erzählt wird sächlich
gestohlen
jetzt gehen sie zu der versicherung
sagen jetzt ist der fall ist eingetreten
das ist gestohlen worden
dann sagt die versicherung vielleicht ja
ist gestohlen worden aber hier im
kleingedruckten steht wenn das gestohlen
wird 20 kilometer von ihrem wohnort
entfernt dann zahlen wenig und im
hintergrund ist es ja so dass die
versicherung sagt wir haben so und so
viel
schadensmeldungen mit gestohlenen
fahrrädern und wir haben eine
anerkennungsquote von 70 prozent 70
prozent bezahlen bis 30 prozent weil
irgendein regelverletzung zahl nicht da
finde ich es wäre zu sagen weg mit all
diesen regeln weg mit den regeln weg und
sagen uns und wir sagen ihnen wenn ihr
fahrrad gestohlen wird
dann haben sie eine 70 prozentige chance
dass ich es ersetzt wird als ihnen
vorzutäuschen
sie haben unrecht mit ihrem anspruch ich
habe eine regel gefunden die zeigt sie
haben doch zwar versichert aber ich
zeige ihnen dass sie gar kein anspruch
haben weil sie die regeln nicht beachtet
haben und das finde ich ein bisschen
fast wie ein taschenspielertrick ja aber
dann die alternative wäre dass der
zufall entscheidet und das spielt der
achim buch eine rolle also jetzt nicht
beim fahrraddiebstahl sondern beim
gericht sagen sie sogar als provokativen
vorschlag warum nicht einfach den zufall
entscheiden lassen ob jemand schuldig
ist oder nicht und würfen bei um gerade
ist er schuldig und bei gerade
unschuldig ist das nicht zynisch
komplett das wäre wenn es so leicht
verkürzt wie sie es geschafft haben da
drin stehen ist das dagegen recht ich
habe sie ein bisschen anders aufgehört
ich sage man müsste man könnte sich
überlegen zum beispiel ob man später
nicht gegen die abschaffung von regeln
oder von strafrecht aber ich sagen kann
sich überlegen ob man an bestimmten
stellen in das system regel fremde
prinzipien ein arbeiter da kommt der
würfel richter ins spiel
man könnte sich zum beispiel vorstellen
scheidungen wo sie zwei zerstrittene
ehepartner haben bevor die jetzt vier
jahre in irgend prozess gehen mit
anwaltskosten usw
wenn man denen anbieten würde und die
sind beide einverstanden und sagen wir
dürfen das aus ich weiß nicht ob es für
die unterlegene partei nicht besser
verträglich ist ich habe halt pech
gehabt als sie hat vier jahre
prozessiert hat viel geld für anwälte
ausgegeben hat nerven das hat nerven
gekostet und verliert dann weil
irgendein gerichts hat wenn du hast
unrecht gehabt
sein anspruch gibt es gar nicht oder
jemand der einen renten leiden hat
sieben jahre durch prozessiert am
schluss verliert mit irgendeiner
begründung wenn man dem anbieten würde
das ist in einer woche abgeschlossen
keine anwaltskosten nichts und du hast
50 prozentige chance wenn alle arbeiten
beim einer halle einverstanden sind dann
es klingt das prinzip ja meistens ist ja
nicht so meistens behalten beide seiten
im recht zu sein und wollen deswegen
einen fairen prozess das könnte man ja
den parteien im zivilrecht könnte man
das überlassen könnte sagen wir haben
auch die anderen möglichkeiten machen so
oder ihr geht den anderen weg wenn ihr
das wollt ich bin nicht so sicher ob es
nicht den einen oder anderen geben würde
dir sagen würde 50 prozentige chance
keine anwaltskosten in einer woche im
urteil
ob das nicht für manche fälle eine
attraktive alternative werden zumindest
etwas über das wir nachdenken kann und
sollte sie bezeichnet sich ja gern als
pragmatiker und beziehen sich darauf
koloman den sorgen von thomas mann der
der meinte jedes prinzip führt zu
absurditäten wenn man es bis zu seiner
letzten konsequenz der wirklich was fast
dem so ist was sagt das denn über unsere
vernunft ist das ist eine schwachstelle
unserer vernunft und das ist das
angesprochene prinzip der
generalisierung tendenz im ersten modell
und in der tat eine gefahr und ich finde
diesen satz von golo mann den finde ich
fantastisch weil er das auf den punkt
bringt und das erkannt hat ich glaube
das ist etwas eine schwachstelle auf die
wm aber auch menschen 3 steht oder das
folterverbot das sind acht prinzipien
heißt es dann ich glaube es gibt keine
absoluten prinzipien
ich glaube die idee das ist absolute
prinzipien gibt die immer und überall
und für jeden fall das richtige sind und
gültig sind das möchte ich stark infrage
stellen heißt das dass unsere unser
verstand gar nicht zur welt passt also
bei der verstand oder die vernunft ist
dadurch ausgezeichnet nach kant zum
beispiel dass man allgemeine sätze
prinzipien herstellt und wenn du jetzt
nie mit der wirklichkeit übereinstimmen
dann das ist ein schönes beispiel für
polarisierung absolut hat das würde ich
nie sagen ich würde sagen es ist quasi
schwarz weiß entweder oder 100 prozent
oder 0 prozent würde ich jetzt sagen
eine generalisierung und absolut die und
das sage ich nicht sagen ich nie sagen
es besteht die gefahr dass wir dinge die
wir für richtig halten orden und reden
dass wir ins absurde überdrehen und so
generalisieren dass sie zu absurden
konsequenzen führen
so wie das golo mann auf den punkt
gebracht hat und dieser reform muss man
sich bewusst sein und ich denke an
vielen stellen wäre es wäre es dann viel
sachgerechter wenn man das dann wenn man
dem sowohl als auch gerecht wird statt
dem 0 oder 100 prozent dem entweder oder
können sie vielleicht noch mal ein zwei
spiele machen wo das verhängnisvoll ist
wenn man ein prinzip bis ins letzte
konsequent durch denkt und anwenden also
gut das kann man bei jeder
extremistischen ideologie sagen kann man
da kann man kann man sie die verirrungen
und verwirrungen von gute kann man sagen
die prinzipien sind ja aber die menschen
die das vertreten die kommen ja also
sind ja die größten schweinereien in der
weltgeschichte und die die schlimmsten
sachen sind damit den edelsten
prinzipien verbunden und die menschen
haben wir dann immer gesagt die müssen
absolut angewendet werden also das fängt
ja schon in der aufklärung selbst die
aufklärung endet ihr aber den jakobinern
da drin dass man die prinzipien so
überdreht dass am schluss alle auf der
guillotine lang und dieser umkehrpunkt
den glaube ich gibt es in allen theorien
prinzipien in allen standardisierungen
und der ist ein gefährlicher wir sind
schon fast am ende der zeit eine letzte
frage was ist denn eigentlich schlimmer
eine welt der es an vernunft mangelt
oder eine welt der es an gefühlen
mangelt beides gleich schlimmen und
beides muss zusammen kommen und ich
glaube die vernunft ist ein sehr sehr
sehr gutes werkzeug um
probleme zu vermeiden um schlimme dinge
abzustellen um zu besseren lösungen zu
kommen ich bin da sind wir auch noch
nicht so weit wie wir uns fühlen
technisch zwar aber ansonsten
evolutionär sind wir noch nicht so weit
wie wir denken aber ohne gefühl und
mitgefühl ohne emotionales erfassen geht
das gar nicht und sie kennen das aus
meinem buch ich mach die trennung ja
sowieso nicht so zwischen denken und
fühlen sondern ich glaube für unser
gehirn gehört ja beides zusammen wir
trennen das von außen auf unser gehirn
ist das eine art und weise wie wir
informationen registrieren wahrnehmen
und verarbeiten das gehirn dem ist es
egal ob wir das gedanken oder ob ihr das
gefühl denn spanien herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
dann gehen jetzt gleich gibt's richtig
große und schöne kunst ein porträt über
den französischen maler claude monet
tauchen sie ein öffnen sie ihre sinne
und schalten sie die vernunft für einmal
ganz aus wenn sie können wir sehen uns
nächste woche
[Musik]